[MUSIC PLAYING]
BRIAN LEVEE: Hi, I'm Brian
Levee, a product manager
on the Google Docs team.
And this is Allen Yang, another
product manager on the team.
Nowadays, people use a
number of tools at work
in order to get things done.
Over the last few
years we've worked
to integrate Google Docs
into the G Suite applications
as well as third party tools.
But in order to further
improve users' workflows,
we know that we need to
go further to seamlessly
integrate Google Docs
into the applications
that users use most.
All right, I'll do it,
I'll do it by hand.
Today, we're going to go over
existing integrations that
are offered by Doc
Sheets and Slides
as well as introduce three
new types of integrations that
are currently in development.
We have Slides add-ons,
Templates integrations,
and Storage integrations.
We've been working with
a number of partners
on these new
integrations, and I'm
excited to have
two of them with us
here today to walk us
through the integrations that
are currently being worked on.
Let's start with the
existing integrations
offered by Google Docs,
add-ons in Docs and Sheets
and API for Sheets and Slides.
Docs and Sheets add-ons
allow third party developers
to add functionality
that allow users
to accomplish new workflows
within the editors.
Add-ons can be installed from
within Docs and Sheets using
the top level add-on
menu, and then
are installed from
within the editor
through the Chrome Web Store.
Add-ons can interact with
Documents and Spreadsheets
in a number of manners including
showing sidebars and dialogues
within the editor.
We've seen add-ons in Google
Docs that have performed
a number of use cases.
There are add-ons that make
it easy to insert and create
diagrams directly in
your document, add-ons
that provide writing aids
to users to check grammar
and document readability.
There are add-ons that
offer translation services,
as well as business tools
such as Document Signatures,
and Templates.
Lucidchart is an example
of a popular add-on
in Google Docs that
makes it easy for users
to insert as well as to create
diagrams ranging from my mind
maps to flowcharts and
other types of diagrams,
all from within the
Google Docs Editor.
Sheets add-ons as
well has been created
for a variety of use cases.
We've seen Sheets
add-ons that allow
for cross-product
integrations, add-ons
that pull in data from
external sources such as Google
Analytics and third parties.
There are add-ons that help
with advanced formatting
in order to make spreadsheets
look professional,
as well as add-ons
that provide workflow
assistance such as Automatic
Document Creation and Mail
Merge.
Let's take a look at
yet another Mail Merge,
which is a popular Sheet's
Add-on, in this case created
by an independent developer.
Yet another Mail Merge
makes it easy for users
to import their contacts
while in Google Sheets
and then send mail merges
without even having to leave
the Google Sheets Editor.
That was add-ons
for Docs and Sheets.
Last year, we also introduced
APIs for Sheets and Slides.
These APIs make it
easy for developers
to pull and push data
and content in and out
of spreadsheets
and presentations,
making it easy to automatically
generate spreadsheets
and presentations,
as well as keep them
in sync with third party tools.
Whereas, you saw add-on
user flows typically
starting from within the
editor, API user journeys
often start from the
third party tool.
We've seen the Sheets
API used for integrations
across a variety of
use cases including
syncing customer
data with your CRM,
making sure your timelines
stay in sync in the spreadsheet
with your project
management tool,
and exporting data
from the tools
that you use most
into Sheets to make
it easy to manipulate the data
and create visualizations.
Let's take a look at
an example integration
that Asana created
using the Sheets API.
From within Asana, users
can view project dashboards
in order to see how
projects are going
and keep track of what's
going on on their teams.
When you're managing
a number of teams
this quickly becomes
difficult to do.
So Asana used the
Sheets API in order
to allow users to open these
reports in Google Sheets where
they can create visualizations
that make it easy for the team
leaders and managers to keep
track of what's going on
and identify what areas
need their attention.
In addition, leveraging
the Sheets API,
Asana was able to keep the
data in Sheets up-to-date
with any changes
made back in Asana.
Sauna Similarly,
the Slides API has
been used for a
variety of use cases,
automatically
generating presentations
that pull in customer
data from CRMs,
adding project updates to
presentations from project
management tools, and exporting
diagrams, visualizations,
and other content.
ProsperWorks used the
Slides API in order
to allow users to tag templated
fields in Google Slides
with metadata that allows
ProsperWorks to pull
in associated customer
data directly from the CRM
into dynamically
created presentations.
No more having to manually
copy-paste all of this customer
data from the CRM into each
new presentation that you make.
ProsperWorks makes it easy
to automatically generate
these presentations
for you, saving you
a lot of time and
energy, and creating
dynamic presentations that
merge with your customer data.
So we've covered add-ons
in Docs and Sheets, which
bring the power of third
party tools into the editors,
as well as APIs for
Sheets and Slides, which
allow spreadsheets and
presentations to stay
in sync with third party tools.
We've gotten great feedback
from both our users,
our customers, and our partners
on these integrations, which
is why we're very
excited to announce
three new types of
integrations in Google Docs,
Sheets, and Slides that are
currently in development.
We have Slides add-ons,
Templates Integrations,
and Storage Integrations.
To walk us through
these new integrations,
we're going to
introduce Lois a sales
manager at a retail company in
the Midwest who's going to help
us walk through some examples.
I'll now hand it over
to Allen to walk us
through add-ons in Slides
and Template Integrations.
ALLEN YANG: Thanks, Brian.
And thanks to all of you
for being here today.
We're really excited to share
what we've been working on.
So Lois is wanting to
make a presentation
to help pitch a new product
line to her senior leadership.
In order for her slides
to be successful,
they're going to need to
be punchy and polished.
As you know, Google
Slides is a great product
to help you make
presentations that
are beautiful and
collaboratively made
with your team.
Today, we're very
excited to announce
that the same add-ons framework
that exists for Docs and Sheets
today is coming
to Slides as well.
Soon, users will be able to
use Slides add-ons to leverage
partners such as Balsamiq,
Lucidchart, and Adobe
Stock in order to insert
beautiful diagrams
and photos into their slides.
We made Slides add-ons
with the intent
to help users become more
efficient by eliminating
unnecessary context
switches, and we'll
see what that means
in a little bit.
First, let's take a look at
what our partners at Adobe Stock
have come up with.
Lois has drafted her
deck, but now she
wants to add a bunch
of high quality images
in order to help
emphasize her point.
To do this, she
thinks there might be
a Slides add-on that can help.
So she visits the top
level add-ons menu
and goes into the add-ons store.
In the store, she
notices that there
is a new add-on from Adobe Stock
to help her with stock photos,
so that's the one she
chooses to install.
Using this add-on,
Lois now has access
to Adobe Stock's entire database
of high quality stock photos.
And using this
add-on sidebar, she
can search through those
photos by category,
such as icons, as well as search
by theme, such as workplace.
For any particular
photo, she can
choose to buy the license
to use that photo,
she can preview it
in her slide, or she
can look at similar
images from Adobe Stock.
When she is settled on the
photos she wants to use,
she can log into Adobe Stock
using either her Adobe Stock
credentials or using
her Google account.
Previously, in order to
accomplish the same workflow,
Lois would have had to
open a new tab or window,
browse through the
partner's database
there, purchase the
licenses to those images
there, and then import those
photos back into Slides.
But now, with this
new Slides add-on,
Lois is able to accomplish
the same workflow
all within the Slides interface.
This is exactly what
we mean by saying,
we want to reduce
unnecessary context switches.
So moving on into
deck, Lois wants
to create a rather
complex process flow
diagram to help her
company troubleshoot
defective new designs.
Normally, she could do this
by creating a bunch of shapes
and slides, filling
those shapes with text,
connecting them with lines and
arrows, and then figuring out
how to lay those out on a
slide in an appealing way.
But what if she had access to a
more powerful diagramming tool
like Lucidchart?
Well, we're excited to announce
that our partners at Lucidchart
are also working
on a Slides add-on.
With this add-on, Lois can log
into her Lucidchart account
and see a list of all
her previous diagrams.
Lois remembers that
at one point in time
she did create a
troubleshooting flow.
And indeed, she finds it
here in her list of files.
She is able to preview this
diagram in the lower right
corner of the add-on sidebar.
And by hitting the
blue insert button,
she can insert that diagram
as an image into her slide.
After doing this,
though, she realizes
that she wants to make
a couple of small tweaks
to this diagram.
So she hits the Edit button
in the middle of the sidebar
and gets taken to
Lucidchart's powerful new web
diagram editor.
This allows Lois to use the full
power of the Lucidchart tool
to edit the diagram
in any way she wishes.
When she's done, she
can return to her slide.
And by simply hitting
that refresh button
in the lower right hand corner,
the new version of the diagram
will replace the old version.
Great.
So Lois now has successfully
completed her diagram slide,
but she also wants to create
a few wireframes of what
the web page for this new
product might look like.
To do this, she can use
the Balsamiq add-on.
Balsamiq is a great tool
that helps you quickly create
wireframes and prototypes.
Lois has installed
the Balsamiq add-on.
And she notices that it connects
with her Google Drive, which
is where Balsamiq
stores all of her work.
Using the add-on,
Lois can browse
through her entire list
of all Balsamiq projects
that she's worked on.
And with the
sidebar she can even
search through those
different projects.
When she double clicks
on a particular project
she can see the individual
wireframes or marks
that make up that project.
And she gets a preview
of each of those mocks.
For any given mock, she
can hit the Edit button
to be taken to Balsamiq's
powerful web editor, which
brings the full
experience of Balsamiq
to bear on any diagram
she wants to edit.
When she's done, she can go
back to slides and insert
the wireframe or
mock into her slide.
Later on, she knows that
if she makes any edits
to a particular
mock or wireframe,
she can always refresh
all the mocks in her desk
to get the latest version.
These are just some
examples of Slides add-ons
that our partners
are working on.
If there are any
developers in the room who
would be interested in
working with us to develop
a Slides add-on, please
feel free to drop
us a note at the
URL on this slide
because we'll be opening
a Trusted Tester Program
in just a couple of months.
If you're excited to
use Slides add-ons,
they'll be coming
out later this year
and we're excited to have a
great set of launch partners.
That will be in the
Chrome Web Store.
Using this new
integration, Lois is
able to create a
beautiful presentation,
successfully pitch her new
product line to leadership,
and get it approved.
She then goes out to
a potential supplier
and negotiates a great
deal for her company,
but now she needs to
encapsulate that negotiation
into a formal document that
both parties will sign.
To do this, our next Docs
integration will help.
Template integrations.
As you may know, towards
the end of last year
Google Docs released the
ability for companies
to have their own internal
company template galleries.
And at this point, I'd love
to see a quick show of hands
for anybody who has
had a chance to try out
these new galleries in the Doc
Sheets or Slides home screens.
Great, great,
decent number here.
Terrific.
Well, we hope you've
enjoyed that experience.
And if you haven't had
a chance to try it yet,
we highly, highly
encourage you to do so.
So template integrations are
the next step in Templates.
A template integration is a
pairing of a specific template
with a specific add-on.
With this pairing, we're excited
to bring the power and domain
expertise of our partners
to the flexibility of Google
Docs, Sheets, and Slides.
This feature is coming
out later this year
and is currently
under development.
But at launch there will be a
set of Google curated template
integrations as well as the
ability for enterprise users
to pair their own templates with
any add-ons they have access to
and upload that pairing
to their company gallery.
Let's take a quick look
at how this helps Lois.
So Lois suspects
that her company
has a number of boilerplate
legal contract templates.
So she goes to the
Docs home screen
and looks at her company's
internal template gallery.
Indeed, there she
finds that her company
has a standardized sales
order form, which she can
use for this particular case.
And she even notices that
there is an add-on attached
this template.
So this is the one she selects.
She gets taken to the
editor, seeing the template,
but she also notices that
this template has compared
with the DocuSign add-on.
Turns out Lois's
company uses DocuSign
for all of its electronic
signature needs.
And one of Lois's coworkers has
helpfully created this template
and paired it with
the DocuSign add-on
to be uploaded to
the company gallery.
And this way, Lois knows
exactly the right tool to use.
Through this new
sidebar, Lois is
able to kick off the insulation
flow for the DocuSign
add-on, which will then
request the permissions it
needs to run.
After it's finished
installing, Lois
is able to launch the DocuSign
add-on from the sidebar.
This means that Lois
had the right tool
ready at her fingertips
for the appropriate moment.
This is accomplishing our
goal of making workflows more
efficient for enterprise users.
So this DocuSign
add-on is actually
a new add-on that's
currently under development.
DocuSign is a recommended
for G Suite partner
and already has a
number of integrations
with other parts of G Suite.
Their new Docs add-on is
their latest integration
and so today we're very excited
to have Marshall Nam, Product
Manager at DocuSign, who
will walk us through what
this experience looks like.
Thanks, Marshall.
MARSHALL NAM: Thank
you very much, Allen.
Quick show of hands, I'm
curious, how many of you
have heard of DocuSign before?
OK, so I have a good,
friendly audience.
Thank you, this is good.
How many of you have actually
signed a DocuSign document
before?
So about the same number.
I'm going to say
about 85% of you.
And this is the real test, how
many people here have actually
used DocuSign to send
a document to somebody,
to get a signature
from somebody else?
So that number cut by about
2/3, only about a third of you
have done that.
And that's good.
That's good.
I think I have something
very cool to show you,
you'll get to see the other side
of that signature transaction
that you've been part of before.
And you'll also see how we're
using the power of Template
integrations to really
unlock additional value,
make things a lot easier for
people that are using both G
Suite and DocuSign together.
So Louis, Lois, now that she's
installed the DocuSign add-on,
using that very easy and
intuitive experience,
first gets a summary
of the different things
are going to happen when
she goes through a DocuSign
transaction.
So for this sales form,
she'll click start,
and the first thing
she'll do, she'll
have that document automatically
imported into DocuSign,
and she'll see a quick
preview of it there.
But if she needs to add
additional things, maybe terms
and conditions, some
supplemental forms, things
she has to do for
her company, she
can reach right back
into Google Drive
and pull those additional
documents in right there.
And since we're integrated,
we can automatically
pull her information as well.
And we recognize that the
way that the template is
structured, since
it's add-on ready,
we know that she's going
to be the first signer
on the document.
And for Olivia, her
customer that she's
signing this deal with,
all she has to have
is her name and
her email address.
And she fills that in, and it
continues to the next step.
And now DocuSign will notify
her that she has something
available for your signature.
And for those of you have
signed with DocuSign,
which was about 85% of you,
you've seen that email before.
On this side, you can
actually customize that email
and send a message maybe
saying, hey Olivia, it's Lois.
This is the document,
the sales order
form we agreed on,
please sign this.
For the third of you
that said that you've
been through this
process before,
this is the most time consuming
part of DocuSign in the sending
experience.
This is the part where
you take the document
and you have to actually
mark on the document-- this
is where you're
going to sign, this
is where you have
to add your name,
this is where the
date is going to go.
And through the power of
the template integrations
that we have now available
to us at G Suite,
we've done something
very interesting.
If you remember back to
the original document,
it looked like a
normal document,
completely blank in all
those different fields where
you had to sign and add data.
But because this
is DocuSign ready,
because it's integrated
with this template,
we have automatically recognized
all the different places
where Olivia has to
put her signature,
where she has to fill
in her name, date.
Those are automatically
recognized and marked.
And not only that, you can see
in the upper left-hand corner,
since are two signers
on this document,
Lois, if she scrolls
down, it's also
recognized her fields
as well and recognized
which ones are hers.
So all of this has
been automatically
done for her because of that
strong template integration
that we can do with
Google technology.
At this point,
Lois can go and she
can add an additional
initial fields
on some of these
supplemental forms
and make sure that
Olivia is going
to read these documents
before she goes through that.
At that point she's done.
Olivia, sorry, Lois can go and
she can sign her own document
first.
This is a sign and
countersign example.
She'll click right
here, her signature
comes in, she can fill in
these additional fields.
And that's the magic
behind the curtain.
I think from this
point, everybody here
that said they signed a DocuSign
document before, they're
used to this experience.
And you can see, as most of
you know, Olivia will come in,
she'll agree--
we're actually doing
something very interesting
on the legal side to
protect your business,
making sure that
people acknowledge
the electronic signature
records and signature
disclosure, which makes
us the legal equivalent
of a written signature.
And we make this really
intuitive guided process.
If you click on that
Start button on the left,
Olivia, when she
clicks that, she'll
be guided right to the point
where she needs to sign.
That's automatically recognized.
Those are all filled out.
She'll initial those and
she'll finish the document.
At this point, this is
a lot of the real magic
of making all this
process digital comes in
because on Lois's side she's
received an email notification
that that has been completed,
and that Olivia has
come and signed that document.
She can go and she can
look at the document
directly from that email,
see all this information.
And what's really interesting
on her side, what you may not
have known is very
important for this,
she can actually go and
look and see everything that
happened in this transaction.
This is not a scribble
on a piece of paper.
You can see every single action
by every single person that
was taken on this document,
when it was viewed,
when it was sent, when it was
signed, did somebody look at it
and sign it later?
And you have a time stamp,
and you have an IP address,
and a Geo IP if it's
on a mobile device,
for everything that happened.
So you have an incredibly strong
legal protection for this.
This is something that you
want for your business.
It's also something
very interesting.
I think it changes
things culturally.
In sales organizations like
Lois, some of our customers
tell us there is a new term.
Since they get
rich notifications
of when different things happen
in the process, at the end
of the quarter some
of our sales teams,
they tell us there's a new
phenomenon called Docu stalking
where they will actually
go inside of DocuSign
and hit refresh over,
and over, and over again.
Has my deal closed?
Have they signed?
No more actually
taking a document,
printing it, putting it in a
FedEx envelope, and praying.
That's the old school.
Well, now we've
moved to the Cloud.
Now that we've gone digital,
we've done that with G Suite,
it suddenly becomes
entirely digital
and something that becomes
a rich digital transaction
for you.
And that's what we're
really trying to do.
We talked about
the days or weeks
that it might take for a
FedEx envelope to get sent out
and come back to you.
No more of that.
No more days, no more weeks.
Actually, 84% of
our transactions,
since were on the Cloud, we know
are signed in less than a day.
Actually, about half of them
are signed in less than an hour.
And take all those costs that
go into, costs of lost business,
costs of sending,
signing, printing,
we actually save
about $36 per document
for our customers for every
single document that they sign.
And in no small part
thanks to the reach
that we get with G Suite
and the Google ecosystem,
we're bringing 150,000
new customers, new users,
into our ecosystem
every single day.
And I talked about us wanting
to make every single approval,
agreement,
decision-making process
digital for our customers.
We want to do that
in all of our,
everybody's favorite
G Suite applications.
So we have
integrations with Docs,
which email, as Allen
mentioned, we'll
be having a Docs ad-on coming
in at the end of this month.
And we have an
Android app as well.
I think sometime around
a year and a half ago we
started seeing more people
signing on mobile devices
than we saw signing
from a desktop
or from a standard web browser.
So our Android has been
a huge part of that.
In our Android application
we can sign Sheets,
we can sign Docs.
And all new for this
year, we recently
refreshed our entire design to
fit with Google material design
standards.
So very interested to
help people like Louis,
very interested to help
all of you out there,
and very excited about
this new template
integration and this
partnership with Google.
Thank you.
Allen?
[APPLAUSE]
ALLEN YANG: Thanks, Marshall.
We're really excited about
the new DocuSign add-on
and about all the other
add-ons that can soon be
used in Template integrations.
So if you're a
developer out there
who's interested in creating a
Template integration with us,
we'd love to hear from you.
Please fill out the
form at this URL.
Otherwise, Template
integrations will
be coming out later this year.
And we're super excited
about the great set of launch
partners we have for it.
Partners including DocuSign,
Balsamiq, Lucidchart,
Supermetrics,
PandaDoc, and EasyBib.
So with this new
integration, Lois
was able to successfully
get signatures
that she needed on
her sales order form,
launch her new product, and
help her company grow wildly.
So to move on to our next
new Docs integration,
we'd love to have Brian
come back and take the mic.
BRIAN LEVEE: Thanks, Allen.
Raise your hand if
you occasionally,
or even regularly, use
a storage provider other
than Google Drive.
OK, so I'm seeing a fair
number of hands in the room.
Previously, if you
worked at a company that
was using a storage provider
other than Google Drive,
there was no good
way to use Google
Docs to edit your content.
We're working to solve this.
We're working on
a new set of APIs
that will allow users to create
and edit Google Docs files that
are stored and managed by
third party storage providers.
Last year, we announced
our first partner
in this effort, Box.
Today I'm very
excited to announce
two additional partners
that we're working with,
Egnyte and Citrix.
We're working with
Egnyte and Citrix
in order to allow joint
customers to create and edit
files using Google Docs that
are stored and managed in Egnyte
Connect and Citrix ShareFile.
With these
integrations, users will
get the best of both Google
Docs collaboration and Machine
Learning functionality
alongside the powerful storage
and workflow functionality
offered by Egnyte
Connect and Citrix ShareFile.
I'd now like to invite
Ronen Vengosh onstage,
VP of Business
Development at Egnyte,
to introduce Egnyte and walk
us through a user journey using
Google Docs with Egnyte Connect.
Thanks, Ronen.
[APPLAUSE]
RONEN VENGOSH: Thanks, Brian.
Very excited to be here today.
For those of you that--
going the wrong way, here we go.
For those of you that are
not familiar with Egnyte
we are an enterprise
file sync and share
company, among other things.
We're a content intelligence
company, to be exact.
We have two product lines.
One is Egnyte Protect, which
is a data governance solution.
And our second product, which
we'll be talking about today,
is Egnyte Connect.
Egnyte Connect is an enterprise
file sync and share solution
that's widely deployed.
Around 14,000 business
customers around the world
use it across a
range of industries.
And one of these customers
is Design Within Reach,
which is a joint customer
of ours and of Google's.
And Design Within
Reach was founded
with the vision of getting
heirloom quality design
within reach of the public.
And they use Egnyte
and Google Docs
both in their headquarters,
as well as in their 34
studios around the country.
And one of the cool
things about those studios
is that consultants that
work in these studios
do not have their own
individual machines.
So there's a pool of
machines, a pool of computers
that are available on the floor,
and individual consultants
are able to access their
content securely and immediately
through any one of
those machines, right?
So let's walk through the user
experience of a consultant
that works in one
of these studios.
Her name is Debbie,
and she wants
to work on a new
proposal for a customer.
So to do that she walks up
to any available computer
on the studio floor,
fires up Egnyte Connect,
which is the user interface that
you see right there in front
of you, and without
any complication
at all, right from
the Start menu
she can fire up
a new Google Doc.
And the document is
set up, ready to go
with all the features
that you'd expect
from Google Docs, all of those
things work right from there.
But the cool thing
is the document
is now stored and
managed behind the scenes
by Egnyte, which means that
all the security policies, all
the permissions, all the
policies that have been created
by the IT management are
right there to help her,
and she doesn't need to take
any additional steps to share
and manage that content.
So Debbie edits
the document when
she feels it's in
good shape enough
to share and get some assistance
from other members of the team.
She can, for example, assign
a task to her teammate Gary.
The task can have a due date.
Gary gets a
notification, he knows
that Debbie is asking him
to review the document
and comment.
All of this is very
simple for Gary
because, again, the
permissions are already
set because he
already has access
to that folder in Egnyte.
And so he can come
in and do his work
without any additional
complication.
Other members of the team,
again, behind the scenes,
can go in, add their own
comments, their own ideas.
All of this is the standard
functionality of Google Docs,
but now is available in a
much simpler way for folks
using Egnyte.
So once everybody's happy with
the version that was created
and it's time to share
this with the customer,
Debbie is able to do that right
from within the Google Docs
interface, right?
So by clicking the sharing
functionality over there,
she gets a sharing
model that pops up.
And then all the advanced
features and sharing
capabilities that Egnyte
brings to the table
are available to her.
She, for example, can
password protect the document,
send a link that expires
after a certain time
or on a certain date, and all
the other good things that you
can do with Egnyte Connect.
Once a document gets
to the customer,
even if the customer
for some reason
doesn't have a Google
account, they're
able to view the document even
without starting a new account.
So they can do that right
from within Egnyte Connect
without an additional account.
Very cool stuff.
But that's just the
beginning, right?
Because even though you have
all this functionality of Google
Docs and Egnyte, the real power
comes from the company's side,
from the enterprise side,
where all the policies
that the organization has set to
enforce the sharing of content,
the security of content, are
handled behind the scenes
by Egnyte Connect.
The organization has an audit
trail of everything that's
happened with the document.
Who opened it?
Who touched it?
Who edited it?
When did they do that?
What devices they did that from?
And of course, that's something
that comes in very handy
in cases of an audit
or a legal challenge
or anything like that.
And the user experience, while
all these security features
are happening behind the
scenes, all this power
is there, from the
user's perspective
things are actually much simpler
than they were before, right?
So Debbie can start
this document right
from within Egnyte Connect.
She doesn't need
to context switch.
She can also do that from the
Egnyte desktop application
that she's got on her machine.
So really the best
of both worlds--
the user's happy, the
administrator's happy,
and things are
going the right way.
So to sum it up,
I think the power
of this type of integration
is really in the fact--
as Bethany Kemp of Design
Within Reach says--
the ability to let employees
focus on their customers
rather than on
managing the content,
doing all the hard work
and the heavy lifting
behind the scenes.
And the rest just
happens by itself.
So we're very, very excited
about this new integration
with Google Docs, and
we're looking forward
to making that available
to our customer base.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
BRIAN LEVEE: Thank you, Ronen.
Great.
So in this session
we've covered a lot.
We walked through the existing
types of integrations,
which include add-ons in Docs
and Sheets and APIs for Sheets
and Slides.
And then we introduced
three new types
of integrations
that are currently
in development, Slides
add-ons, Template integrations,
and Storage integrations.
We saw integrations
from large partners
as well as from
independent developers.
And we walked through use cases
that spanned design, legal,
and marketing.
I want to thank all our
partners for working
with us to integrate Google
Docs more seamlessly into users
workflows.
And a special thanks to Ronen
and Marshall for walking us
through some examples.
For those who would
like to learn more
about Google Docs
and integrations,
here are a few sessions that
are related to this talk.
The top Machine Learning and
Explore in Google Docs, these
are all occurring tomorrow,
sessions on G Suite
integrations and leveraging
App Script APIs and add-ons,
as well as leveraging
Google Docs and G
Suite in order to empower
your legal and sales teams.
[MUSIC PLAYING]